[Musik]
das podcast ist bei rm unique sind wie
in europa in der filme gerne zeit
heute werden wir händische belassen wie
diskutieren die nächste woche
chinesische film city dann danach
afrikanische klubs wie dann zwei wochen
islamische glosse wer also das wissen
weihnachten und vielleicht sogar
weihnachten hinaus sind der außerhalb
der des europäischen zusammenhangs und
einerseits ist irgendwie naheliegend
dass wir diese handelsnationen bestachen
vor allem die indische tradition da
diese tradition sehr für tätig sehr
bekannt ist sie wissen wahrscheinlich
alle dass viele ende vegetarier sind und
das dass es regionen in indien gibt es
die gewalt gegen tiere entweder völlig
ausschließen oder mindestens minimieren
wollen vor allem sind vielleicht die
johnson bekannt
vielleicht haben sie diese diese zb
fotos von james gesehen die zum beispiel
mit maske darum gehen damit sie keine
inception schlucken und die insekten
töten oder sogar mit einem besen entlang
gehen und sehr sorgfältig die den fan
von abwischen umsätzen aus dem weg zu
schieben damit sie nicht auch sie treten
wir werden heute die philosophische
begründung für diese haltung ist ob wir
diese haltung und weise sprechen also
einerseits ist irgendwie offensichtlich
das zu diskutieren
andererseits wenn man die liste der
lehrveranstaltungen her an deinem nun
der im fach philosophie anschaut oder
die beamten veranstaltungen in ganz
deutschland
oder weltweit infos wie da fällt auf
dass das professionelle philosophen
anscheinend den eindruck haben dass wir
fast nur im europäischen kontext
existiert und da ich jetzt dann wie
gesagt für die kommende woche
klasse die ab also außer europäische
philosophie beschreiten werde dachte ich
dass es vielleicht interessant werde nur
kurz was dazu zu sagen
die die frage ob philosophie als er hat
ja europäischen gesellschaft und kultur
existiert ist weniger interessant als
man vielleicht meinen könnte bzw ist die
frage ist gar nichts interessant weil
die antwort einfach klar jahr heißt und
das aus weiteren erstens wenn man die
wenn man unter philosophie nur das
versteht was von den alten dann abhängig
ist also texte und koalitionen
intellektuelle creation die zurück zur
griechische philosophie zurückgehen dann
muss man sofort anerkennen dass wir
nicht europäische flüssige nation in der
geschichte haben die mit kritischer
philosophie sehr eng verwandt sind und
das wird zu fahren für das vieh in der
islamischen welt
wenn wir das erreichen wenn sie das
nicht aus anderen dörfern schaltungen
schon kennen werden wir sehen das futter
für das vieh in arabisch waren sehr
stark von griechischer flosse
beeinflusst wurde und nicht nicht mehr
oder nicht weniger als zum beispiel für
das vieh im lateinischen mittelalters
und diese philosophen leben zwar
teilweise in europa zum beispiel gab es
muslimische denker wie es im zwölften
jahrhundert die in
analysieren gelebt haben das heißt in
spanien vorwiegend ist aber die
islamische philosophie viele situationen
eine ein als europäisches phänomen also
ist eigentlich hauptsächlich in irak und
iran sind zwei hasen beheimatet also von
daher wenn man sich selbst nennt man so
dass hang sehr streng ist würde sehr eng
aufgestellt ist
mit der mit der einstellung was sie ist
oder sein könnte
man könnte fast sagen dass europäische
philosophie auch bis zentralasien
erreicht hat also dann gibt es eine
weitere fassung dieser frage gibt es für
das sich wie in anderen kulturen die mit
griechenland nichts zu tun hatten oder
sehr wenig mit griechenland zu tun
hatten
zum beispiel china afrika einheimische
volk von den amerika und indien gibt es
auch in diesen kulturen philosophie und
da ist noch mal die frage nicht
interessant die frage ist nicht deswegen
nicht interessant weil wir indien haben
ist eigentlich ja
sie meinen haben also unter den zu
merken können oder ich bin ich bin ich
bin amerikanische film so sanio johnson
gesagt hat ich weiß eingepflanzt
es gibt eine interessante frage ob es
lasse sich in den kulturen gab die die
in den amerikas existiert hatten bevor
die europäische common sense zum
beispiel da ästheten und in kals und da
lautet die antwort noch mal ja also wir
haben relativ viele informationen über
die flüsse field der hahn in calls und
azteken
das werde ich aber nichts in diesen
dieser vorlesungsreihe bestreichen
aber es war schon ein bisschen gegen
wörz ist natürlich auf jeden fall was
ich was ich kann
die wie wir in zwei wochen sehen wenn
die frage was denn das ist wie in der
burghalle jahres in afrika asien
geschäfts gesellschaft war ist relativ
kontrovers also da gibt es eine
interessante frage
chinesische verlasse die würde ich sagen
ist relativ unumstritten dass lucentis
muss und tourismus und so weiter für
diese tradition sind mit irgendwie auf
der hand
also man sieht dass sie ethische werte
hatten politische lehre auch
metaphysische ideen dass es irgendwie
relativ überzeugend aber indien ist der
beste fall glaube ich weil man in der
englischen tradition nicht nur für
solche texte findet sondern texte die
sehr offensichtlich viele solche texte
sind also ohne frage wird es häufig sind
und auch texte die die ganze breite der
friesischen tragen abdecken die wir
kennen und nicht wegen ein plus von den
heutigen sondern unabhängig ist eine
sehr häufige frage ist ob es doch
irgendwie einfluss von indien nach
westen gegeben hat oder umgekehrt
und die antwort da ist sowas wie ja
vielleicht aber eher wenn dann eher
einfluss von indien hat europa mit
umgekehrt und sowieso haben wir auf
jeden fall mit 200 hauptsächlich mit
zwei unabhängigen traditionen zu tun die
sich irgendwann gegenseitig beeinflusst
haben
aber ich sage mal leuten also menschen
die sich ernsthaft fragen oder zweifeln
ob es wie in antiken india gegeben hat
das sind buchstäblich personen die
weniger als zehn die medica als zehn
minuten
genommen haben sich damit zu
beschäftigen es gibt jetzt geregelt
keine ernsthafte frage und und in david
loosli ist auch nicht nur die existenz
sondern ist auch sehr ausführlich und
ist eine sehr lange komplizierte
tradition die heute nichts wirklich
schildern kann weil indische klose wie
als als tradition genauso kompliziert
und lang ist wie europäischen flüsse sie
also europäischen philosophie und
entwicklung sowie sind ungefähr gleich
groß sozusagen als als teile unseres
faches tatsache dass wir ähnliche weise
wie in westlichen universitäten nicht
beachten hat wirklich nichts mit nichts
mit dem inhalt zu tun hat nur mit dem
mit der ausbildung der westlichen
philosophen zu tun
japan also japan da bin ich nicht so fit
mit japan aber soweit ich weiß ist
japanische krise wie er eine dass da hat
man mit wirkung von chinesischen
philosophie zu tun
in japanische kultur also was ist was es
vor also für ältere ideen in japan jedem
hat die nichts mit buddhismus zu tun
haben oder kann er konfuzianismus zu tun
haben das weiß ich nicht aber es gibt
auch eine lange zwischen der japanischen
und koreanischen flüsse wie die
mindestens oft so der chinesische city
gate also in meine hypothese ist dass
man flüsse wie dort findet wo man
menschen findet so viel los wie ist
gehört irgendwie zudem so nennen
grundbedingungen oder grund phänomene
die auftauchen waren auch immer man
menschen hat und die frage ist nur
passiert darüber wissen können zb wenn
wir uns fragen was war die philosophie
der menschen der steinzeit
dann ist das eine schwierige frage zu
beantworten aber hauptsächlich deswegen
weil wir so wenig informationen dazu
haben aber wir können irgendwie davon
hast sie hatten auch viele solche ideen
die frage ist nur was wir darüber wissen
können durch archäologie und so weiter
das ist natürlich sehr also das ist
natürlich eine sehr breite auffassung
und sehr also maximal offen sie will
sich in anderen kulturen was ich jetzt
sagen wollte ist nur dass man nicht so
breit und offen denken muss um indien
als heimat ein heimat der philosophie
anzuerkennen weil indische texte einfach
offensichtlich philosophischen und wir
können heute ein beispiel davon sehen
die stadt dann im allgemeinen indische
philosophie aus das ist natürlich eine
eine mit ganz einfache frage
aber im prinzip hat man zwei gruppen von
gruppen so sagen es gibt zwei hälfte so
sagen die wäsche schulen und die nichts
weniger schulden und manchmal sieht man
sieht man das wort schramma für die
nicht schwedische dass das sind die
haben die leute die praktische
ausländischen der der hauptströmung
beendigen gesellschaft ausgestiegen sind
sozusagen und die sitten und werte der
des bürgerlichen indischen volkes und
wann die bahnen dann abgelenkt haben
das wort wedig manchmal sieht man das
wort brach manisch hat natürlich mit den
veden zu tun die werden sind sehr alte
texte die so alt sind und noch älter als
die gedichte die immer noch existieren
unter dem namen von roma und hesel ist
sind sehr alte texte zum teil
die dann eine reihe von anderen
textformen dann erzeugt haben sozusagen
oder inspiriert haben
in der ersten linie die upa nie schaden
[Musik]
japanisch schade das ist mehr ein genre
als ein text ist eine art von text die
über jahrhunderte produziert worden ist
es gibt sehr sehr viele japanische
hatten aber die früheste in panik
schaden kann man also sagen ein eine
zweite welle oder schicht der vedischen
literatur
man kann es so verstehen und oft
verwendet man das wort wegen sogar für
die ursprüngliche werden und die
japanisch an zu sagen eine schule der
indischen floss wie auf dieser seite
heißt vedanta also das was nach den
werden kommt das heißt das ist eine
auslegung der rub ami schaden und in der
restlichen und in diesen wenigen texten
geht es darum das sind natürlich sehr
komplizierte texte habe unter anderem
geht es darum die götter zu beschreiben
oder legenden
vielleicht sagen mythen über die götter
zu erzählen aber auch kosmologische
ideen auszudrücken in viele ideen über
rituale die in dieser kultur sehr
wichtig waren
genau wie in der antiken europäischen
kultur die wir letzte woche gesehen
haben und ich werde dann später so
kommen würde total und vor allem opfer
zu sagen aber im grunde genommen was man
wissen muss ist dass in der plasma
nischenkultur man diese berühmte vier
schichten hatten und die obere schichten
waren die drachmen also die priester und
die shuttles die kämpfer oder die dieses
vielleicht soldaten oder die die
kriegsherren und typisch für diese
beziehung war dass der priester der
kriegsherr helft richtige zu opfern
damit er das von den gott und bekommt
was er haben will
zum beispiel reicht vom sieg im krieg
söhne mit seiner frau und so weiter und
dann genau wie diese ritualen
funktionieren sollen
und was der priester da machen muss das
wird in den läden thematisiert und auch
in dem totalschaden
aber wie wir auch heute sendern kommt es
oft vor dass man eine fast alle
griechische oder abstrakte auslegung des
opfers findet wo sie zum beispiel die
sprache des tieres benutzen um das ganze
universum zu besprechen und so weiter
aus dieser tradition entstehen mehrere
schulen die wir normalerweise als die
inder shiv philosophische schulen
bezeichnen und manchmal verwendet man
hier das wort orthodox das habe ich
absichtlich nicht gesagt weil ich weil
ich das problematisch finde in dem das
dem wird dann implizieren würden dass
die schwarmer bewegung also die
hektische bewegungen hetero dogs sind
und das klingt ein bisschen abwerten
also das fängt als ob man so sagen die
linke seite ist richtig also orthodox
heißt natürlich richtig denken oder
richtig richtige glaube und dann werden
diese diese schulen auf der rechten
seite werden die falsch denke die die
falsch gegangen sind und aus der
ethischen perspektive stimmt das
natürlich aber aus unserer perspektive
als historiker ist das natürlich nichts
sagen wollen
also ich habe versucht eine andere
bezeichnungen zu finden aber in der
literatur werden sie oft the dogs und
hätte dort finden also die sechs
sogenannte orte vox schulen oder ich
würde sagen dänische schulen oder
panischen schulen sind die ich auf dem
herd hier gelistet haben ja in welcher
schicker seine yoga und mir meine tante
ich glaube es wäre vielleicht
überflüssig zu erklären was all diese
schulden kennzeichnet aber nur kurz
naja und jessica sind die zwei stunden
für logik und metaphysik sozusagen also
im jahr macht logik analyse der
argumente der technologie zum beispiel
wie kann man eine feststellung durch
eine kausale begründung rechtfertigen
und da sehen sie schon wie
offensichtlich es ist dass das
philosophische texte sind also wir haben
wirklich
paradebeispiele von
t oder beweise die man geben könnte und
dann erklärungen was ein gutes argument
ist was ein schlechtes argument ist uns
und wie man die man wissen begründen
kann dass naja bei schicker ist eine
atheistische mathe physik die dann
vielleicht könnte man sagen dass sie die
welt erklären wollen dass naja dann
argumentativ herangehen will mancher und
yoga sind eines also sammler ist eine
touristische auch mette physische oder
kosmologische theorie die eine eine
dualistische anthropologie auch
voraussetzt
yoga ist dann die praktische anwendung
dieser theorie wie man die die
körperliche existenz durch diese
juristische auffassung dann meistern
kann
mit mama und vedanta sind etwas näher an
dieses das ist natürlich alles immer im
hinblick im hinblick auf die gehälter
der texte hamster und bekannte sind eng
mit den texten verwandten haben wirklich
sehr spiel mit auslegungen der texten zu
tun
vor allem hat mir monster sehr viel mit
denen zu allen zu tun also jetzt das ist
da würde ich sagen dass das bereich der
fluss sieht was dazugehört ist irgendwie
philosophie verhandlungen und für das
wieder sprache weil sie da analysieren
wollen wenn es zum beispiel einer
rituale steht dass man um sowas zu
erreichen soll man das und jenes machen
was ist die beziehung zwischen
dieser forderung und die handlung des
open den menschen oder wie funktionieren
diese aussagen sprachlich gesehen dass
hamster und wie dankte es wie gesagt
eine analyse der mitte zwischen
behauptungen in der japanischen da ist
wird und die kassen von bedankte die wir
bei einem club namens chunk oder finden
weitere dante haben sie weitere gehört
oder und weiter wir dann heißt nicht nur
wie dante beamten halte meinen kam will
sagen dass die ganze welt eine art
erscheinung von einem gott christ und
hat weitere tante die dualität zwischen
diesen gott und der welt vereinen also
das heißt diese erscheinung oder wir
kommen gottes ist nur illusorisch es
gibt ein am ende nur gott deswegen nicht
wahr es gibt kein es gibt nicht gott
umfeld es gibt nur gott
man kann deswegen sehen das elegante und
samt ja fast genau gegenüber gesetzt
sind also bei st sehr ausdrücklich
zulässt ist wie tante hat eine neigung
in der kommunismus etwas sehr starken
bei schwankender vorkommt wobei es auch
bekannte denke gibt die dual denken
wollen
es gibt die wie man die anhand dieses
beispiels sehen kann gibt es spannungen
innerhalb der schulen zum beispiel
innerhalb wie dante gibt es touristische
richtungen oder sumpf traditionen und
dann gibt es ja flüssen die gegen
tourismus fürmann ismus erschweren
dann gibt es spannungen zwischen den
schulen zum beispiel zwischen meine
wegen st ja und alter bekannter also die
beziehungen hier sind sehr komplex und
oft was wir bei diesen texten finden ist
eben ist ein ebener argumente von einer
schule gegen die anderen schulen
natürlich auch von der vedischen
perspektive gegen
die firma denke das kommt auch vor aber
was sehr oft vorkommt ist ist die
elektrische auseinandersetzung innerhalb
einer schule oder zwischen zwei
vedischen schulden das kommt auch vor
also sehr sehr kompliziert aber nichts
kommt jetzt endlich kompliziert und auch
nicht weniger kompliziert als
europäische floss wie also wenn man wenn
man daran denkt dass es ähnlich wie
alles sozialismus neue tourismus doris
muss und dann gibt das streit innerhalb
der platonischen tradition und streit
zwischen den katholiken
den ersten teil in köln zwischen den
platonischen hat die telekom in den
story kann und so weiter ist hier
englisch
es gibt sozusagen genau so viel zu
wissen hier wie in der antiken flüsse
wie in europa ist wie gesagt nicht groß
der unterschied ist dass man sozusagen
gegen gesellschaftlichen traditionen in
europa kam wendet es gibt zum beispiel
die zyniker die wirklich so happy es
sind also sie wollen wirklich aussteigen
heißt normalen gesellschaft und die
werte der gesagt hat gesellschaft völlig
abwerten und ablehnen
das passiert aber sehr wenig in der
antiken europäischen pluscity vielleicht
waren die früher historiker so gemeint
aber mit der zeit wird es muss sehr
drastisch sogar also sehr gut bürgerlich
bis zu dem ergebnis dass wir sogar ein
stalker als römischer kaiser hat es gibt
sie mag oder es gibt nichts weniger
gesagt nichts weniger außer hat die
gesellschaft als der römische kaiser so
sein
also man kann so ist es nicht aus eine
gegen gesellschaftliche bewegung
definieren wäre
wir hier sozusagen die hälfte der zeit
mit gegen gesellschaftlichen flüssigen
bewegung sie tun haben und hier gibt es
mehrere beispiele aber die haut
beispiele sind natürlich die podesten
und die kleine ist
allerdings gibt es auch viele solche
schulen die etwas schwieriger
einzuordnen sind paradebeispiele werden
schabacker die werden soweit ich weiss
man nicht normalerweise habe ich das
charme einer bewegung bezeichnet aber es
sind sehr offensichtlichen gegen
mindestens die wette physische und
psychologische theorien der vedischen
schulden weil sie nicht naturalistische
oder physikalische theorie der
philosophie des geistes haben zum
beispiel dass wir uns mit solchen sind
nicht so wichtig aber nur noch mal so
sein müssen ist selbst diese wieder und
zwar ist nichts vielleicht geschuldet
was historisch stattgefunden hat
auf jeden fall was was die buddhisten
und djs auch die packers kennzeichnet
ist dass sie die ganze die ganze
gesellschaftliche und religiöse richtung
der bayerischen kultur ablehnen
sie glauben nicht dass ritualen jede
sogenannte früchte bringen können also
du kannst du kannst laut dieser
tradition nichts an diese opfer und
irgendwas erwarten das funktioniert
nicht und außerdem ist die ganze gäste
die ganze reihe ordnung der
gesellschaftlichen schichten irgendwie
falsch sie wollen aussteigen die wollen
diese die sitten der sogenannten
haushalte zum beispiel diese cash at
kriegsherren das wollen sie ab nennen
die ziehen sich zurück
neben in kleinen gruppen zusammen die
dann später größer werden bis zu dem
ergebnis dass sie sogar universitäten
begründen sieht das kann sehr groß
werden
aber am anfang müssen wir daran denken
wir haben mit keinen meiner abschlüssen
gruppen zu tun
die zusammenleben und zusammen
philosophieren so waren wahrscheinlich
die frühe bruder buddhisten und janis
und genau wie wir dialektische streite
und argumente innerhalb der wenigen
schulen haben so hier haben wir
innerhalb jeder tradition innerhalb der
schwamm eine seite der geschichte und
von der stirne seite gegen die
bayerische seite sehr ausführliche
argumente und philosophische
auseinandersetzungen zum beispiel die
finals in zwei hälften die sogenannte
himmel
bekleidete und weiß gekleidete himmel
begleitet heißt nacht es sind menschen
die nachts leben um ihre enthaltsamkeit
und asketisches leben still zu
unterstreichen und sie seiten gegen sich
ist jenseitig zum beispiel hat man hat
diese gruppe gedacht dass es nicht
annehmbar ist dass frauen drastisch
leben weil frauen nicht nachts wenn man
andere gehen können umgehen können
werden die weiß gekleidete channels
frauen musste belassen haben zb dann
gibt es streit zwischen den buddhisten
und den channels innerhalb der des
buddhismus zu wissen scheint dass es
viele arten von buddhismus gibt da gibt
es immer auf die webseite und dann gibt
es seit zwischen den buddhisten und die
und den vedischen denken also noch mal
sehr kompliziert und werden wird sogar
noch komplizierter weil die solche
entwicklungen die wir innerhalb einer
schule beobachten oft nicht nur
abgelehnt wird von den handelsschulen
meine ich sondern auch übernommen und
unser hauptthema heute ist ein sehr
gutes beispiel dafür
weil wir heute das hauptthema irgendwie
für heute ist die idee dass man keine
gewalt ausüben muss natürlich tiere
gegenüber
das was unter dem titel aber auch im
allgemein man soll keine gewalt ausüben
das ist die sogenannte ethik von hamza
nicht gewalt und diese neigung oder
diese ethische überzeugungen fängt auf
dieser seite ein wird aber sehr schnell
von den vedischen
übernommen und wird ganz in die
skisaison charakteristisch das heißt
dass man heute wenn man ein hindu kultur
denkt denkt man oft an auch ein zb weg
der terrorismus nicht dass alle handys
vegetarisch sind aber viele schon und da
sieht man diese unterscheidung gar nicht
weit da haben wir auch vegetarismus
das ist gerade deswegen weil
vegetarische ethik und nicht
gewalttätige ethik wahrscheinlich bei
den jameson aber auch die den buddhisten
angefangen hat würde aber so schnell
wäre schon schon übernommen dass das
keine differenzierung ist und die frage
ist ja deswegen nicht unbedingt gewalt
schlechter sondern wie wir es wieder so
fisch begründen wollen warum ist gewalt
schlecht oder warum sollten der gewalt
vermeiden seid da ist die antwort
irgendwie eine gemeinsame antwort
nämlich dass gewalt mit schlechtem karma
verbunden ist weil alle schulen noch mal
an karma und normalerweise auch an
wiedergeburt glaubt also diese ideen
sind irgendwie gemeinsam zu allen
situationen aber die furcht die
vorstellung aber von kammern die man in
jeder tradition findet ist jeweils
anderes selbst zu sein selbst wenn sie
miteinander zu stimmen
haben sie auch meinungsunterschiede also
mehrmals betont habe ist das alles sehr
konzert in ich werde viele
unterscheidungen einfach ignorieren
damit das relativ viel besser klick wird
aber nur damit sie wissen das ist alles
viel komplizierter als es heute ist
dann würde zu zur frage der ablöse
bekommen wir vielleicht mache ich kurz
pause fast jemand fragen hat zu der
allgemeinen position ja mein kompass
hinduismus das wort hinduismus ist
schwierig oft hier manchmal wird die
linke hälfte als einfach als die händler
esstische hälfte bezeichnet eben ein
hemd heißt nur indien und irgendwie
zurückblickend würden viele hindus sagen
des hinduismus mit den werten anfängt
wenn man das nicht wenn man nicht bereit
ist das wurde hinduismus dafür zu
verwenden dann muss man entscheiden ab
wann man von hunden tourismus stärken
will
also war für ganz antike indien werde
ich ein bisschen vorsichtig weil es halt
auch das hat auch nationalistische
betonung wenn man von handys muss
pflicht weil man wenn man bedenkt dass
das ist was heißt was indisch aber das
ist natürlich auch indisch also ich
vermeide das wort handy erst wenn du in
diesem zusammenhang normalerweise nur
damit ich die also nicht weil ich ist
unbedingt falsch finde aber sondern weil
ich nicht ganz sicher bin dem wir und ab
wann man das ansetzen soll
aber man könnte vielleicht sagen ab
derzeit der spätantike wo diese schulen
zuerst kristallisieren und die
sogenannte das hätte ich erwähnen müssen
es gibt das wort sutra wird das heißt
daten und unter anderem was dieses sechs
schulen und auch die kvg-schule
kennzeichnet ist dass sie dass die texte
haben die für die ganze philosophie
koalition dann fundamental sind und die
heißen normalerweise
schule sozial so yoga zu tragen zum
beispiel nicht immer aber wir haben
diese sehr kurz gefasste und sehr schwer
verständliche texte die dann eine
weitere schicht von auslegungen dann
gefordert haben diese auslegungs texte
haben heißen was ja und das heißt dass
wir für jede schule fast jede schule
eine sucht ein super text haben und dann
ein rascher text der autor aktiv die den
zurzeit ex auslegt und dass wir bei den
buddhisten und wenn es nichts die haben
auch es gibt auch so zu also bei den
buddhisten aber das heißt was anderes
das heißt mehr wie sprache oder
anekdoten oder sowas
und vielleicht könnte man sagen dass hin
dass die da entsteht bodysuit und basis
entstehen und das ist grob so in der
zeitung uns also in der europäischen
spätantike also in der zeit von 9 es
muss zum beispiel andere fragen
sie meinen also praktisch über was jetzt
afghanistan impressionist ja ja es gibt
es gibt mehrere bücher zu dieser frage
und auch zu der frage ob deutlichen nach
indien gereicht haben und irgendwo ihnen
wieder was gelernt haben oder viele
ideen dahinter transportiert haben
also da bin ich eher skeptisch dass wir
nicht weil ich viel darüber gelesen habe
war etwas was ich gelesen habe mit mit
so beeindruckt hat es gibt viele
ähnlichkeiten zwischen alter philosophie
und in deutschland los wie aber die
ähnlichkeiten sind auch relativ
oberflächlich zb tourismus denn in
meinen bleiben kulturen optimismus aber
ich denke immer wenn man philosophisch
daran denkt was ein körper ist dann
kommt man sehr schnell zu dem ergebnis
dass man das körper entweder hat hat aus
atomen bestehen oder nichts
also man kann entweder in einen körper
bis ins endliche schneiden oder nichts
wenn nicht dass man hat und ist von
daher bin ich neige dazu bedenken dass
die behörden punkte zwischen alt-
kritische oder römischer philosophie und
indische dass wir relativ gering sind
aber einfluss würde ich ausschließen
was ich aber doch ausschließen würde ist
das sozusagen alte philosophie nur
deswegen entsteht weil die eigentlichen
irgendwie mit östlichen traditionen in
kontakt waren oder umgekehrt
so hat cedrick haben wir mit zwei
unabhängigen solchen kulturen zu tun
und dann gibt es eine weitere frage auf
ob und wann sie dann in kontakt
miteinander
kommen aber dass das passiert erst
nachdem sie und am helden entstehen
sozusagen anderes anderes ausgedrückt
man kann europäische antike + ich sehr
gut verstehen ohne was über indische
philosophie zu wissen was gut ist weil
die experte für einen titel positiv was
sich war es nicht auskennen mit
indischen und umgekehrt
und umgekehrt kann man hinter klose wie
sehr gut verstehen ohne alte schiffe
dass sich super stellen
obwohl es vielleicht berührungspunkte
gibt
ja das ist eine gute frage also kenne
ich mich nicht so gut aus wobei ich
kenne jemand der sogar für das wie die
medien unterrichtet sein das ist ähnlich
wie in der islamischen welt zum beispiel
ich glaube auch in china dass man
versucht beide versionen auf werk zu
halten also sie lesen was oder wer
kündigt ein wasser oder hegel was auch
immer aber sie machen auch die haben sie
haben auch indisches wie und es gibt
dann immer die frage die wie man in all
diesen kulturen natürlich kommt
irgendwann kontaktnetz europa um
gegenseitig und die frage ist immer wie
viel sie übernehmen wollen
und manchmal hat man den eindruck dass
die dass die ente oder chinesen oder
muslime dafür kritisiert werden dass sie
nicht mehr von europäische philosophie
übernehmen wollen
aber man muss schon sagen dass also die
die kultur die wirklich zu wenig
neugierig war waren immer die europäer
also dass schotten habe oder so gibt es
was keine westliche für das offen die
bewusst sehr viel von den östlichen
traditionen übernehmen werden das in die
gegensätzliche richtung ist das
überhaupt nicht der fall wie man die
also indische philosophie würde also die
inter würden natürlich bezwungen
ähnliche ideen zu übernehmen wegen
kolonialismus und das trifft auch bei
weil der islamischen welt zu
also in in einer typischen indischen
universitäts heutzutage ist so weit weg
weiß kann man westliche philosophie
studieren aber das heißt das schließt
nicht aus dass man auch die japanischen
lesen
zum beispiel englisch hier glaube ich
allerdings nicht so einfach mal okay
frage und leben hindurch muss heute wird
das extrem instrumentalisiert das wort
und die hindus die spanischen durchsagen
kleiner sind
während ja sagen somit können kleine
videos also das ist natürlich heute
alles es gibt natürlich auch gegen islam
das ist unter anderem ein grund warum
ich das wort vermeiden
okay gut
ein ausflug machen als klasse
oder oder hamza hendawi klappt glaubt
die von ihr hätte wahrscheinlich was
dagegen zu sagen wegen
sicherheitsrichtlinien
also ich kann mal nachfragen ob es
zugelassen dass tiger dann tiger tiger
zeichnen da bin ich nicht so gut drauf
war okay gut so das ist ein irgendwie
ein guter übergang zu tiere in der
indischen locity und grob werde ich
diese unterscheidung jetzt folgen und so
erst tiere in der rhätischen koalition
besprechen und deinen tiere in den stamm
einer bewegungen also bei den bilden
anzufangen und bei den panischen das
erste was gleich auffällt ist das was
ich vorher erwähnt habe nämlich dass die
ritualen die da gesprochen werden
mindestens manchmal oder dies nur
manchmal mit tier opfer zu tun haben
nur manchmal weil man auch pflanzen
opfern kann
aber es ist sehr groß oder in den
härtesten werden zum beispiel indem
blick weder dass man auch an die opfer
denken eine berühmte passage und es oft
die erste passage die man in
zusammenhang von indischer philosophie
dann eingeführt ist eine passage wo es
beschrieben wird das einen mensch oder
person das wollte das produkt kann
später das heißt person vielleicht sogar
seele manchmal dass ein dass eine person
pressure zergliedert wird und somit
wieder werden die verschiedene
gesellschaftliche schichten und die idee
es offensichtlich dass man diese person
aufschneidet genau wie man das mit einem
tier machen würde
dein tier opfer und ähnlicher weise in
einem glaubt ja sogar der ältesten
panisch hat das heißt große wald
harnisch hat ist nicht so leicht aus
werken aber hat der an japanischer kommt
da haben wir ganz am anfang eine passage
wo ein werks nichts nichts geopfert wird
aber die teile des körpers des pads
werden mit verschiedenen aspekten des
universums verglichen
das hab ich dann auf dem herner
geschrieben
diese länger als das was ich geschrieben
habe aber manchmal muss man vielleicht
erwarten würde ist dass die teile des
tierkörpers mit teile des kosmos dann
vergleichen verglichen werden könnte
aber das ist komplizierter oder
abstrakter zum beispiel sein kopf ist
die dämmerung
wahrscheinlich weil der kopf vorher
steht aber seinen rücken ist ist himmel
seine knochen sind die sterne usw
also es gibt eine ganze liste von
körperteile und was die cosmo ins becken
der kosten logische teile sind das ist
übrigens typisch für die japanischen
weil ein
so seien ein öffentliches thema was
durch viele spanische und asiatische
texte oder passagen dort geht dass man
zwei phänomene nimmt und vergleicht die
aspekte von diesem phänomen mit die mit
aspekten von diesem phänomen und die
idee ist anscheinend eine unterliegenden
unterliegen
struktur in der natur zu finden wird es
für den mann auch zum beispiel zwischen
dem universum und dem mensch das zum
beispiel luft oder wärme in dem mensch
den menschen am leben hält
und genau deswegen ist luft irgendwie
ein grundlegendes prinzip in der natur
er ist übrigens ein beispiel wo wir hin
die keinen zwischen gleiche philosophie
und alt in der pluscity finden wir
natürlich bei den pussycat die ganz
ähnliche ideen könnten zum beispiel luft
bei ajax minis ist auch das haupt
prinzip wahrscheinlich aus dem gleichen
grund man sieht dass alle tiere oder
viele tiere atmen müssen dass luft die
tiere am leben hält
und das ist ähnlicher weise der fall
sein muss dass luft irgendwie ein
wichtiges prinzip oder sogar ein
belebendes prinzip für das ganze
universum sein könnte aber noch mal
würde ich hier vermuten dass diese
überlegung irgendwie so offensichtlich
ist dass das einfach zweimal ab
unabhängig und am ende auftaucht
aber als er auf jeden fall interessant
zu sehen dass wir in der diesen alten
englischen texten
genau das sie sehen was wir in der
hallischen texten gesehen haben nämlich
das tier körper als paradebeispiel
verordnung gute organisation technologie
dann finden also wenn diese texte ein
beispiel oder ein ein vergleich finden
wollen um das auszudrücken dass du das
universum gut gestaltet wird ist dann
nehmen sie den tierkörper als analog
weil tierkörper offensichtlich gut
gestalten sind und
und wir gute ordnung haben ok und wie
gesagt kann man auch in diesen passagen
lehrinhalten passanten sehen dass das
opfern eines tiers ein grundlegendes
republik in der teil der vedischen
kulturen der vedischen sitten war aber
wahrscheinlich und das ist noch diese
übrigens unter anderem genau wiegen die
diesen nazistischen ideen über
hinduismus ist immer kontrovers aber es
wäre sowieso konnte wäre es war so
verschwommen ist und so geschichtlich
selbst schwer zu sagen ist immer schwer
zu sagen abwarten und genau wie wir
einfluss von samana zb bewegte sich viel
bewegen auf handy tradition haben aber
eine hypothese könnten wir sagen
wahrscheinlich hat diese nicht
gewalttätig hier angefangen und hat dann
diese seite infiziert sozusagen
nehmen wir das einfach an das scheint
sehr früh angefangen zu haben
und das heißt dass wir schon irgendwie
sorgen wegen gewalt schon bei enns ist
sehr weit weg in die weschnitz version
sehen zum beispiel gibt es ein paar
berühmtes werk in der welt installation
die heiß mannes magic city das
gesetzbuch manus heißt dieser titel
und da ist eine sehr schöne passage die
zeit wie schwierig das thema war in der
zeit wo dieser text geschrieben würde
oder wahrscheinlich er komponiert wurde
das heißt aus verschiedenen texte
zusammengestückelt würde sehr viele von
diesen texten übrigens vielleicht was
alle von diesen texten
daran würden erstens zuerst mündlich
überliefert und zweitens sind
zusammensetzungen von verschiedenen
materialien sind ein sehr gutes beispiel
werde das beim thema hatte das ist
zusammen
das literarische werk indiens oder eines
davon was die werke homers entsprechen
das auf dass die dass das mache barbara
viel viel länger ist als beide roma geht
es zusammen ist riesig das heißt oder
also nach valetta heißt so also das
heißt das ist sehr groß ist
das ist die geschichte wird heißt was
sehr groß ist und es ist in der tat sehr
groß und das würde ich natürlich nicht
von hand geschrieben sondern waren viele
geschichten so weiter die jemand
zusammengebracht hat und das wäre
ähnlich mit diesen mit diesen gesetzbuch
man uns mit herrn gott und das dass es
vielleicht ein grund warum diese passage
über tiere ob es so kompliziert ist man
können sie sich vorstellen dass mehrere
leute sich zu dem thema geäußert haben
und dass jemand das alles ein paar
zusammen getan hat oder vielleicht hat
nur ein mensch das geschrieben aber hat
gespürt dass man spannungen um das thema
schon hatte aber auf jeden fall wird es
da gesagt erstens dass viele tierarten
für uns verboten sind zuerst zweitens
dass die tiere die nicht verboten sind
dass wir sie doch essen dürfen und
opfern sollen sogar dafür dass sogar
gesagt dass diese tiere nur deswegen
existieren dass die existieren damit wir
sie opfern und an hessen dürfen
das ist natürlich nämlich wie in wie ich
letzte woche bei cofidis geschrieben
habe dass man das tier schlachtet und
dann den gott dann anbietet aber
gleichzeitig mit ist so sein
[Musik]
und dann in der gleichung passage
unmittelbar danach wird das gesagt dass
es besser ist gewalt gegen tiere völlig
zu vermeiden
seltsam also wenn man das wenn man eine
eine auslegung hier anbieten will
damit das alles irgendwie stimmt wird
könnte man vielleicht sagen dass der
autor auf jeden fall ritual als sehr
wichtig doch behalten will aber auch
versteht dass gewalt wahrscheinlich
schlecht erst irgendwann vielleicht mit
flaschen kamera verbunden sbb später
sehen werden und das ist deswegen dass
wir vielleicht das in gut beraten werden
gewalt gegen tiere irgendwie zu
vermeiden auch wenn wir weiterhin die
italien ausführen schon einen
vorschlagen die was wir hier und auch in
anderen späteren texten finden
er ist dass man ein ersatz für das tier
findet zb ein huhn schlachtet aber der
hund ist aus teig oder es irgendwie ein
symbolischer hoya und man schlachtet
ihren kopf verdienen
allerdings finden wir auch in diesen in
diesen gleichen texten die aussage dass
ein tier in ihm zusammen haben der
ritual umzubringen ist kein gewalt aber
dass keine töten
das ist also das würde heißen wenn ich
ein elefant sehen würde und nur aus spaß
des elephant erschießen würde das wäre
gewalttätig aber wenn ich ein tier im
zusammenhang einer ritual umbringen das
ist nicht gewalttätig das es erlaubt
wenn man sieht wie wie schwierig das
schon weil die suite ist sie das
empfunden haben
aber ich glaube haben dass die die idee
ist wahrscheinlich dass das dass die
hauptsache hier also was wirklich im
mittelpunkt stellen ist die wichtigkeit
des der rituale und solange man das
ausführt und richtig ausführt ist man
isst man hat man gut gehandelt wurde
gleich gut genug gehandelt
man hat das gemacht was man soll aber
[Musik]
wenn man das macht und noch dazu
irgendwie einen weg findet gewalt zu
vermeiden dass es noch besser also in
der flüsse die haben wir das schöne wort
super joker tores super story auf
englisch es gibt aber das wort deutsch
glaube ich super joker tores kennt
jemand dieses wort vielleicht habe ich
das gerade er von
kennt jemand das wollte jetzt existiert
schon oder
ich habe es aber nach geschlagen wie das
auf deutsch heißt und was ich gefunden
habe ist dass das über das dick maß
hinausgeht
es ist super rhetorisch das heißt man
man macht was man muss oder moralisch
gesehen soll und noch mehr
zb können vielleicht sagen dass es
nichts erforderlich ist das ganze geld
zu spenden und an zu leben aber wir
würden wir werden trotzdem bereits
menschen zu bewundern wenn sie das
machen ja also dass das was wir gefunden
obwohl wir es moralisch nicht
erforderlich einschätzen
das ist das was über das flip massen
haus geht und dass und nicht gewalttätig
sein
diesen texten so auf andererseits gibt
es dass es bleibt eine auslegung dieser
passage in dem gesetz buch aber einen
eine andere auslegung werde dass gewalt
irgendwie innerhalb der ritual nicht
mehr zählt gesagt dass keine tötung mehr
wieso würde man dann einen taifun
hernehmen über vielleicht nur um nur
deswegen weil es eigentlich egal ob man
ein tier tötet oder nicht du kannst auch
ein tier aus teig nehmen solange du die
das opfer über aus fürst das ist alles
was zählt
[Musik]
und diese idee finden wir in einer sehr
raffinierten weise in dem vielleicht
berühmtesten text der physischen vielen
arabischen nationen nämlich die
bürgerrechte
darüber geht er ist ein kapitel oder
teil in den machen dem aha baratta und
es gibt sehr viel darüber zu sagen aber
kurzum das ist die geschichte wo ein
krieger namens an china zurück gegen
seine eigene familie krise führen
was er zu sagen machen soll also ist
eine aufgabe und war er erzeugt sagt
seinen wagen leiter also sein wagen
pilot krishna der zufällige ein gott ist
sagt ihm wieso er da kämpfen soll man
sieht sofort die die frage dieses textes
ist noch mal die frage des gewalt und
man könnte vielleicht sogar vorsichtig
vorschlagen dass ein grund warum dieser
text zu schieben würde war dass sie
genau unseres unser thema überlegen
wollten also die frage was ist die rolle
des gewalzten guten leben gewalt und
vielleicht paradebeispiel gewaltigen
tiere aber ich hier gewaltigen handel
den menschen natürlich als schade also
als krieger muss man überlegen ob es
zugelassen ist krieg gegen andere
menschen zu können
antwort ja wenn es wenn das sei aufgabe
ist wie sollte man diese aufgabe
erfüllen weil es durch schicksal so
gewollt ist und weil man dadurch die es
in der partie gesagt wird das universum
zusammenhält also jeder muss
eine komische so ein komisches 6
erfüllen
und wenn man das nicht macht agiert man
irgendwie gegen die welle der götter das
übrigens noch ein thema was uns leid ein
antiker dass es die herrinnen könnte
nämlich die story kann also die idee ist
also das was dein schicksal das wir so
oder so machen die frage ist nur ob du
das freiwillig machst oder ob du dich
gegen kämpfst es gibt eine schöne
passagen von den stärken wo es gesagt
wird das schicksal ist wie ein wagen der
ein hund zieht der hund wird mit gehen
ob er will oder nicht
aber es besser für den hund wenn er
freiwillig mitglied und ähnlicher weise
hier wird ein schöner wird es also nie
gesagt dass er kämpfen muss und kämpfen
wird und die einzige frage ist was seine
einstellung ist aber da wir ist auch
gesagt dass die richtige einstellung
nichts das ist dass er die aufgabe
erfüllen soll
mit der absicht irgendwas zu erreichen
zum beispiel siege oder reichtum oder
erde oder ruhm was auch immer er ist
soll das nur machen aus diesem grund
nämlich bald die gottes wollen
es soll jetzt aus party machen das heißt
so was wie liebe an die kartei also die
er soll es als promi kalt machen und
nichts dann mit er irgendwas für sich
erreicht und da wir das sogar
ausdrücklich gesagt in der kita dass das
bei opfern auch geld das heißt wenn man
opfert ist die die idee ist zum beispiel
also es gibt dazu ein dom an irgendwas
unternimmt mit hilfe des priesters wo
wenn man es richtig ausführt bekommt
mein reichtum oder ein sohn zum beispiel
und die idee in diesen texten ist
natürlich so hast du das machen das
heißt die sonst diese rituale im haus
führen aber
ist nicht nur wir wollen nicht nur sagen
dass du nicht enttäuscht sein sollst
wenn das nicht hinhaut sondern sogar
sagen selbst wenn du das aus für aus
fürst sollst du das nicht mit der
absicht machen die früchte zu erreichen
oder dass das gewünschte resultat zu
erreichen dass es nur machen weil dein
wunsch zum beispiel einen sohn zu haben
die die gelegenheit gibt die ritual
auszufüllen und das ist was zählt die
die arme
die absicht ist anti gottes zu glauben
und seine rolle als opfer der mensch
haus zu führen und die früchte sind
nebensächlich ist fast als ob unsere
wünsche und unsere unser verlangen
irgendwas zu erreichen nur eine ausrede
ist damit man in diesen wenigen
praktiken dann teilnimmt und das kommt
eben sehr stark in der gerne mal vor da
wir das gesagt dass die der der offener
mensch ist subjekts oder ist dass
betroffene für all die rituale
forderungen also zum beispiel steht da
wenn du ein wenn du reichtum haben
willst du eine kuh nehmen und die kuh
schlachten und so genau
genau also sehr ausführlich beschrieben
wie man es anders machen soll und die
monster das offen sagen ja der punkt
hier ist wenn du jemand bist der cayenne
sohn haben willst dann betrifft lässt
sich gar nichts wenn du einen sonne
haben bis denkst du stellst du unter der
beschreibung und deswegen hast du eine
art pflicht diese ritual auszuführen
aber die dein wunsch ist nur das was
dich in die in die rolle setzt das zu
tun
es ist wirklich interessant war es als
ob man die ganz das was wie eine
handlungs theorie die die handlung
priorisiert stadt den handelnden die
handelnden personen zu kritisieren und
das konzert starken der gipfel ist
natürlich eine sehr allgemeine handlung
steht die allgemein gültig ist aber
haben erstens ist natürlich an unserem
vor allem also gewalt gegen tiere
anwendbar
und zweitens kann vielleicht sogar zum
teil genau davon dass man überlegt hat
war dies soll darf ich dann gewalt gegen
tiere unternehmen wie sowieso dafür dass
machen weil ich der opfer der person bei
opfern der person bin also das ist hier
meine rolle
und dass das heißt nicht dass ich ein
gewalttätiger mensch sondern dass sich
ein offener mensch bin und es gehört zu
dem opfer dass ein tier geschlachtet
wird aber das zählt nicht als gewalt wie
wir gesehen haben haben diese vermutung
dass solche ideen als eine art haben
befürchten oder mindestens
unbequemlichkeit tier gegenüber dass man
gewalt jede ausgibt haben diese
vermutung wird dadurch verstärkt dass
man in sehr frühen texten an
verschiedene anweisungen findet die
genau dieses ziel haben also das ziel
gewalt zu vermeiden
mein lieblingsbeispiel ist kann das ist
bei manchmal bleibt mein holz um eine
ritual zu machen und deswegen muss man
zuerst einen baum und dann wird das
vorgeschlagen dass man zwischen dem arzt
und dem baum ein stück gras
totes glas nimmt nächstes gras auf dem
baumstamm und schlägst durch und die
idee ist dass dein arzt kein lebendes
ding unmittelbar chefs wie soll man das
machen damit man zeit dass die absicht
nichts mit gewalt zu tun hat also es
geht immer um die gewalttätige absicht
und nichts damit zu tun dass man was
unsere perspektive würden wir sagen dass
das ziel ist nicht gewalt zu vermeiden
so eine gewalttätige absicht zu
vermeiden wenn gewalt dann geschieht so
ist das einfach
das erinnert ein bisschen an eine
philosophie theorie namens aber englisch
heißt es und diese theorie werden wir
später in der mitte lag inklusive
vielleicht sehen nicht okay gut so das
war der teil der geschichte über die
schwedische seite und wie vor gesagt
habe das irgendwie was rückwärts weil
diese sorgen über gewalt wahrscheinlich
von der schlamm einer seite gekommen
sind und das wollte ich jetzt besprechen
und aber als sozusagen übergang würde
ich nochmal dieses thema besprechen was
offensichtlich sehr stark mit dem ganzen
ging als ein problem verbunden ist
nämlich karl machen und sie wissen alle
was kammer ist also die die folgen und
deine handlungen könnten dich erst in
dem nächsten leben beim treffen hat
nicht unbedingt gemeinde kann es auch
zum beispiel in diesem leben ins
gefängnis kommen
aber wenn du zb jemanden ermordet auch
wenn du nicht ins gefängnis kommt das
heißt nicht dass du strafe entkommen
hast weil du
als im nächsten leben als zb eine person
geboren wirst die ermordet wird
oder vielleicht als eine art ihrer
strafe oder was auch immer
und das sind hier zwei sachen wichtig
erstens natürlich die ganze theorie des
video geburts und das erinnert uns
nochmal an dem was wir in der kritischen
situation gesehen haben also bei profis
in beiden kategorien den katholiken dass
man gleich sorgen hat dass das die dazu
führen dass man kein gewalt gegen tiere
ausübt weil diese tiere vielleicht
ehemalige menschen das sind vielleicht
sogar dein großvater oder was also dass
diese freie kann man auch hier standen
und ich werde am ende ganz am ende
zurück dazu zu bekommen
aber zuerst an und meines erachtens
wichtiger ist die allgemeine frage von
karma was das was es eigentlich heißt
weil die diese grobe beschreibung die
ich gerade gegeben habe dass es den
verschiedenen schulen irgendwie
gemeinsam der fall aber sehr verschieden
ausgelegt zum beispiel djs denken daß
karma eine hat staub ist was zu der
seele
dann klebt und dann die zukunft dieser
seele beeinflusst ganz andere anderen
vor allem an der ahr an der seite der
vedischen tradition neigen eher dazu sie
denken daß karma eine art einer gesetz
ist was die gotte dann ausführen wobei
kamen mit unbedingt immer mit gott zu
tun hat es kann man keine haupt denken
dass nur so eine art naturgesetz als
einfach das universum ist einfach so
gebaut dass es gerecht ist und das heißt
wenn du was falsches machst wirst du
unvermeidlich dafür bestraft und wenn
nicht bald dann in den nächsten lebenden
nicht in dem text
eben dann irgendwann das kannst du nicht
entkommen die buddhisten haben natürlich
eine etwas andere auffassung
gegenüber kammer weil sie nicht glauben
dass du im nächsten leben noch
existieren wirst weil sie natürlich
nicht glauben dass du in der nächsten
sekunde existieren wirst weil es dich
nicht jetzt wir haben keinen sex wir
können nicht über die dauer existieren
oder beziehungsweise wir existieren auch
nicht jetzt
es gibt keinen satz es gibt keine person
es gibt nur eine zusammensetzung von
eigenschaften die eine kausale
verbindung mit anderen sammlungen oder
zusammensetzungen von eigenschaften
haben zum beispiel die zusammengesetzte
kombination von eigenschaften die in die
diese vorlesungen angefangen hat ist
nichts mehr
die zusammensetzung die im moment
spricht hat aber eine starke ursächliche
verbindung mit ihr in ähnlicher weise
für sie aber ich bin ich bin nicht mehr
also derjenige der die vorlesung
angefangen hat ist nicht mehr hier und
war auch damals nicht da es gibt mich
nichts und das ist gut weil die tatsache
dass es mich nicht gibt heißt dass ich
keine wünschen oder sorgen haben muss
oder kann die wirklich vernünftig sind
weil wie soll ich wissen zum beispiel
dass ich würde das sich dass ich ein
paar das jetzt und deren ende der
vorlesung nicht sterben und sebastian
hess antrat
wer enttäuschen sie würden ein bisschen
weniger männliche +4 hören könnte aber
passieren
das soll mir egal sein weil das bin ich
sowieso nichts da er stirbt ok dann
könne man könnte man denken war die
sowieso könnten könnte man dann das
meint das kann können sie den bundes
völlig egal sein ob kaymer existiert
oder wasser käme und das stimmt
irgendwie alles ist denn egal müssen wir
von dass sie nix wünschen
sie wünschten sieht für sich nichts aber
sonst ist schlecht es kommt schlägt und
das soll man vermeiden oder man sollte
man würde es für meinen sollen denn man
existieren würde was man nicht tut das
als ein bisschen paradox aber trotzdem
haben sie auch eine kammer theorie und
das paradebeispiel für eine handlung die
schlechtes karma bringt in allen
koalitionen ist gewalt nicht nur gewalt
gegen tiere selbstverständlich
offensichtlich ist gewalt gegen menschen
auch schlecht aber überraschenderweise
ist gewalt gegen gegen nichts gegen
diese man das sagen objekte dient die
kein bewusstsein besitzen gewalt gegen
sie es auch schlecht zum beispiel der
baum in dem beispiel den wir vorher
gesehen dass wir vorher hatten mit dem
gras und dem herbst wurde man gewalt
gegen einen baum
vermeiden und djs sind hier sehr sehr
starkes sie haben sehr stark diese
überzeugen dass man auch keinen
gewaltigen pflanzen aus bludenz soll
idealerweise vor allem haben sie die
theorie dass manche pflanzen nicht nur
ein wesen sind sondern lebewesen zum
beispiel anscheinend denken sie dass
übertroffen
das kartoffel ein kartoffel eine
kartoffel ist nicht nur ein lebewesen
sondern ist sehr viel gewesen und
deswegen ist so man es nicht essen
bernd weiß nicht planen
nur ein denn also wenn man das kann man
eine banane kann man das essen auch kann
man gewalt gegenüber steine ausüben zum
beispiel man stolpert über einen stein
sind buchstelle in stolperstein
man stolpert über einen stein und dann
wird man geärgert und kennt dich dann ja
das ist auch gewalt und soll man nicht
machen ist natürlich bei weitem nicht so
schlimm wie wenn man eine kuh schlachten
würde er sei aber trotzdem schleppt und
bringt schlechtes karma und sehr ball
kommt man zu dem ergebnis oder die
realisierung dass man sich was nicht
bewegen kann ohne gewalttätig zu sagen
im 1 daher wird jetzt dreimal
gewalttätiger handels allgemein hand
angestoßen also gewalt und ungewollt
gewalt gegen holzheim gemacht und dann
habe ich mich geärgert das ist auch
gewalttätig also sehr leicht zeigt das
cover zu erwerben und deswegen gab es
die tradition in bei den james und bei
den weg als dass eine andere schlamm
einer bewegung die ausgestorben ist
buchstäblich die die haben ein ritual
wird könnte man das nennen das heißt
alakrana und das heißt dass jemand
versucht möglichst gut zu leben damit
sie möglichst wenig schlechtes karma
haben und auch zum beispiel großzügig
sein damit sie war möglichst gute kamera
erwerben und dann wenn sie bereits fans
stehen sie einfach bewegungslos in einem
feld oder so bis sie sterben also
sterben von hunger oder wahrscheinlich
durch
und der dj ist dass sie selbstmord sie
würden kein satz man das ist nur dass
man bis zum ende des lebens kommen will
ohne irgendwas gewalttätig zu machen
das ist und das kommt immer noch vor
also immer es gibt buddhistischen mönche
die am ende des lebens aufhören zu essen
und einfach ruhen bis die stärken und
also könnt hier könnte man vielleicht
befürchten dass ich jetzt gerade erklärt
habe zeigt dass diese berühmte indische
tierethik vegetarier vegetarier sein
keine tiere schlachten und so keine
tierprodukten er nehmen so weiter das
ist alles doch keine tiere attack das
ist nur eine allgemeine hektik dass das
gewalt gegen tiere ausschließt nur weil
gewalt im allgemeinen ausgeschlossen ist
und das irgendwie richtig
trotzdem ist die porr gesagt habe ist
gewalt gegen tiere ein paradebeispiel
für gewalt und das was sehr umstritten
wird innerhalb der rezeption ist genau
diese art von gewalt mit gewalt gegen
steine oder bäume wurden auch nicht
gewalt gegen menschen weil es irgendwie
offensichtlich dass gewalt gegen das man
gewalt gegen menschen bei meinen soll
die frage ist die die kontroverse frage
ist inwiefern diese diese dieses prinzip
sei nicht gewollt war vor nach der die
tiger genannt würde
inwiefern dieses prinzip gewalt gegen
tiere ausliest und waren ob man fleisch
essen darf oder nicht
wir haben schon gesehen habt der wenigen
seite gab es auch gab es viele die
gesagt haben es gut vegetarisch sein es
gibt viele handys die vegetarier sind
natürlich aber es gibt auch texte in
dieser tradition die rechtfertigen
wollen wieso man fleisch essen soll
das sind ein zusammenhang ohne
gewalttätig zu sein
auf dieser seite ist allgemein
akzeptiert dass man nicht absichtlich
tiere töten soll um sie zu essen dass es
ausgeschlossen mindestens für asketische
mönche in beiden versionen also bei den
jeans und bei den protesten aber das
beantwortet noch nicht die frage ob mein
fleisch essen darf überlegen wir
folgendes beispiel mein freund
schlachtet ein tier und bereitet das
fleisch für seine familie vor hat aber
zu viel fleisch
ruf mich an und sagt peter wirst du ein
steak haben soll muss sich diese nur
wegwerfen
ok und jetzt nehmen wir an ich bin
vegetarier
was sollte ich da machen es scheint
eigentlich egal es ist meint die hat ich
habe das tier nicht selber geschlachtet
und ich hatte nicht vor das tier zu
lassen aber jetzt geht das fleisch
einfach das fleisch ist einfach übel
es scheint irgendwie vertretbar so sein
dass ich das fleisch essen könnte ja
warum
wir würden seien aus telefonischen
gründen wahrscheinlich
wir würden sagen es eigentlich egal also
das ergebnis ethisch gesehen ist gleich
ob ich das hier ist das fleisch esse
oder nicht weil die tatsache dass ich
dieses fleisch esse hat keine wirkung
darauf wie viele tiere geschlachtet
werden also wie es den tieren geht im
allgemeinen bei ist der kühler
herzlich egal jetzt dass die kühe
geschlachtet würde es ist der herzlich
egal ob das fleischwerk geworfen wird
oder ob ich das fleisch esse ja also von
vom nutzen her so sagen also
telepathisch gesehen ist es vielleicht
egal vielleicht sogar besser wenn ich
das fleisch esse war dann kann er spare
ich dass ich sonst irgendwas essen muss
was gleich schlechte wirkung hat hat
geld gekostet oder hat es die umwelt in
dessen zerstört dass die pflanzen dann
geerntet würden müssten um das brot zu
produzieren dass ich esse und so weiter
ist vielleicht sogar besser wenn ich das
gleiche und dann mit dieser überlegung
kommt man es leistet entschluss dass man
übrigens wird übriges live essen darf zu
diesen schlüssen die buddhisten gekommen
habe ich meine aus anderen gründen
nämlich dass es hat das ist nichts mit
resultat zu tun hat sondern mit absicht
genau wie wir vorher gesehen haben
mit dem taifun es gibt eine geschichte
ich glaube seine kleine geschichte aber
es ist trotzdem dazu dass ein könig
einen punsch waffeln und um gewalt zu
vermeiden
oder besser gesagt weil er denkt dass es
besser ist schlachtet er einen hohen aus
teig und kommt in die hölle weil er tot
sind gewalttätige absicht hatte also das
was er erreichen wollte war gewalttätig
als er kommt nicht um gewalt ausüben nur
weil keine tier und bringt um gewalt zu
vermeiden müsste keine gewalttätige
absicht haben aber wiederum wenn du
fleisch ist aber ohne gewalttätige
absicht zu haben
da ist es zugelassen und hat und
vielleicht deswegen war der bruder nicht
vegetarier angeblich
und das ist dass es im buddhismus
zugelassen das sind manchmal dass man so
genannte übrige fleisch übrigens fleisch
test und djs kommt das geliebt weil das
ihnen eine sehr gute gelegenheit gegeben
hat die buddhisten anzugreifen weil man
natürlich weil es nichts normal in
meinem freund nicht als ob die podesten
jeden abend ein fleisch gespeist hatten
es war nur praktische essen kein fleisch
zugegeben wenn fleisch irgendwie im
angebot ist und das sonst nicht genutzt
würden wäre es vermessen aber unter der
region amberg wir töten keine tiere und
wir schauen dass die kirche nicht für
uns getötet werden
das heißt wer wissentlich dass wir sind
nicht die ursache der töten und das
sichert dass unsere absichten zusammen
rein sind aber djs haben dann gesagt
nein das das reicht nicht
du musst auf jeden fall vermeiden dass
gewalt gegen tiere ausgeübt wird und das
ist nicht vielleicht ein kleid war die
idee dahinter dass die podesten doch
fleisch essen wollten und falls ihr mehr
fleisch übrig hat als er braucht würde
ich es essen das über die polizisten
sagen will
aber die jungs haben das ihm vorgeworfen
aber sie aber im allgemeinen haben sie
auch einfach gesagt die maßnahmen die
hier macht und gewalt zu vermeiden sind
einfach zu schwach
schaut uns an was wir machen gewalt zu
vermeiden
wir tragen masken und damit um zu
vermeiden dass der sekten schlucken wir
haben besen wenn wir umgehen
wir gehen nie in der regenzeit sport
weil wir haft tiere vielleicht treten
das wollen wir vermeiden werden nehmen
wir nutzen nie vorher beide seiten ins
feuer fliegen könnten also wir wer das
einzige was wir machen ist das was wir
nicht vermeiden können um so das
überleben wenn wir nicht wenn wir keine
pflanzen hessen müssten sie überleben
würden wir das auch mitmachen
dass wenn wir so seien von der luft wir
uns ernähren könnten das wäre toll
leider ist nicht möglich
erinnern wir uns an profis der auch ist
er auch gesagt hat es ist wirklich
zulassen dass wir pflanzen lassen
ja aber nur damit wir erleben aber aus
ganz anderen gründen was er vermeiden
wollte war dass wir lust empfinden dass
wir den körper stark machen was die
djanes vermeiden wollen ist wirklich
gewalt gegen tiere als ein bisschen
näher zu unserer perspektive sozusagen
in der tätig aber nicht genau dasselbe
weil sie eben mit der ganzen kammer
theorie arbeiten hessens und 2 genau wie
die bei den buddhisten und auch in der
partita wirklich um unsere absichten
geht und nicht darum wie es unbedingt
wie es den tieren geht wobei man zugeben
muss dass diese diese überlegung zu
sagen wenn ich hier werde wie würde ich
wollen dass sie mich behandelt
das kommt schon in diesen texten hauch
vor zum beispiel es gibt einen
buddhistischen text den ich hier wieder
selbst habe dem herrn dort wo es gesagt
wird praktisch ich gehe nicht um
gebracht werden und das ist der grund
warum ich auch keine anderen menschen
umbringen
also wie das sogenannte ja die
sogenannte goldene regeln
also was soll überlegen wie der andere
behandelt werden
irgendwann sollte man sollte überlegen
die ich selber behandelt werden wenn
andere wesen so behandeln und djs in die
podeste nannte diese idee auch
ausgetragen hand damit es auch für tiere
relevant ist also das kommt schon vor
aber die hauptbegründung gewalt gegen
tiere zu vermeiden ist gewalt zu
vermeiden weil es für mich schlecht es
gewalttätig zu sein weil ich durch
gewalt schlechtes karma er werde jetzt
an
zum schluss wird die zu der frage
zurückkommen ob das doch nicht irgendwas
mit wiedergeburt zu tun hat war klar die
die allgemeine annahme über
wahrscheinlich dass ich persönlich
dachte bevor ich das alles gelesen oder
erforscht habe was ich immer dachte war
ja in indien glauben sie an weht sie
dienten also es gibt es gibt es
bewegungen innerhalb indien dass er
gesagt die an wiedergeburt denken und
wenn man an wiedergeburt denkt ist
irgendwie naheliegend dass man keine
tiere essen soll weil man keine menschen
ist und tier das in menschen und unter
anderem ja
und das ist noch das liegt irgendwie
noch mehr hat daran weil wir genau diese
überlegungen bei den handlichen gesehen
haben
spielt das hier eine rolle antwort ja
also die just zum beispiel geben das
schon als begründung
aber man soll folgendes überlegen
erstens das kann offensichtlich nicht
die ganze geschichte sein weil selbst
das denken nicht dass steine vielleicht
vorher menschen waren trotzdem sondern
keinen gewaltigen steine ausüben also
gewalt ist im allgemeinen schlacht und
bringt schlechtes karma und es mussten
nicht ein lebendes opfer sein
es kann alles sein also alle die ganze
welt gibt uns gelegenheiten gewalttätig
zu sein dass man immer das soll
mannheimer vermeiden
es geht nur darum dass sie an
wiedergeburt geklagt haben ist nicht die
nicht die ausreichende und notwendige
bedingung für diese etliche theorie und
außerdem wenn man man man soll es auch
überlegen wenn man an wiedergeburt denkt
es könnte natürlich sein das ist ein
tier gut ist wiedergeboren zu werden und
zwar so bald wie möglich mit meinen weiß
nicht wie es ist ein huhn zu sein aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es zum
langweiler ist vielleicht nicht so toll
und hat wenn ich tun werde und die
chance hätte im nächsten leben als
mensch wieder geboren zu sein würde ich
vielleicht wollen dass niemand
vorbeikommt und mit schlachtet damit ich
so schnell mensch werden könnte wie
möglich die und die sich überlegen
finden wir sogar in einem text den wir
später
in dem zusammenhang der islamischen
werden werden und können sie hier auch
auf 1000 warum anders ausgedrückt wie
die theorie des wiedergeburt gibt uns
sogar ein grund tiere zu schlachten
vielleicht sie nicht zu essen aber man
könnte sich vorstellen also ich habe
einen freund der durch die welt geht und
alle tiere schlachtet die erfindet als
mitleid für die tiere diese armen tiere
befreien sie alle von diesen schlanken
körpern und wenn sie glück haben sind
sie das nächste mal besser haben sie
bessere körper oder sind besser sind
sogar menschen will also ich drücke
diese spinne in der hoffnung dass die
spenden mindestens ein huhn wird damit
ein mensch und das ist nicht lächeln die
man allein von der tg des video geburts
und deswegen finde ich es irgendwie
befriedigend sozusagen wird es so
richtig sehen dass die hauptbegründung
für h m sei eben nicht die theorie des
video geburtshauses hat anscheinend eine
rolle gespielt würde ich zugeben aber es
für mich kein eigentlich keine gute
philosophische begründen
für hänsel und könnte sogar in die
andere richtung gespielt denn natürlich
ja gesagt habe und von daher ist
eigentlich an gut zu bemerken dass das
heim sei ein grundlegendes prinzip ist
also ist es an das ist fundamental für
die ganze ethik und keine folge einer
zum beispiel religiösen religiöser
überzeugung dass die dass die gott mich
bestrafen oder dass tiere vorher
menschen waren oder ist oder sonst was
gewalt ist einfach schlecht an sich und
gewalttätige absichten zu haben ist auch
schlecht es mit es egal ob die
gewalttätige absichten mit tieren zu tun
haben oder nicht
ok fragen zum abschluss des bassisten
bekamen